[Musique]
c'est le symbole de l'inde aux yeux du
monde entier le taj mahal première
destination touristique du pays avec
près de 8 millions de visiteurs par an
un joyau architectural
désormais dans le viseur des
nationalistes inde à new delhi bijoux
shankar jha il est avocat à la cour
suprême ses clients affirment que le taj
mahal construit par un empereur
musulmans au xviie siècle aurait été
édifié sur le site d'un temple hindou
dédié au dieu shiva selon un des statues
de divinités se cacherait à l'intérieur
du monument dans des pièces scellé il
n'y a pas de volonté de démolir le site
ce que nous voulons c'est ouvrir les
murs artificiels situé dans l'enceinte
du monument et cissé statut sacré se
trouve bien à l'intérieur un espace doit
leur être dédié pour les vénérer avec
respect
des allégations démenties par le service
archéologique teinte mais le taj mahal
n'est pas un cas isolé l'extrême droite
indienne réclament réparation et la
rétrocession de plusieurs bâtiments de
style 1-2 islamique c'est le cas de
cette mosquée à bénarès ou encore de ce
complexe entourant un ancien minaret
vieux de 900 ans à new delhi point
commun tous les sites concernés sont
musulmans nous constatons qu'un de nos
sites religieux a été détruit dans le
passé et qu'aujourd'hui notre
civilisation s'élèvent pour leur
restauration c'est quand même bien notre
droit tout ceci se fait de manière
légale n'est aucunement question de
tensions communautaires
si ces actions en justice se veulent
pacifique elles s'inscrivent pourtant
dans un climat politique et religieux
qu'il l'est beaucoup moins ces derniers
mois les actes et les discours
islamophobes se sont multipliés en 6
même moins de 100 parmi nous ici se lève
et deviennent soldats nous pourrions tué
deux millions de musulmans nous serions
victorieux même si nous finissons en
prison c'est l'attitude qu'il nous faut
adopter c'est le seul moyen de sauver
notre religion
appel au génocide ou encore chants
haineux devant des mosquées d action
orchestrée en toute impunité par des
groupes fondamentalistes hindous proche
du bjp le parti du premier ministre
narindra maudit
parmi les dieux visé le quartier déjà en
guerre pourri au nord de l'udps est
désormais étroitement surveillés au mois
d'avril cette zone résidentielle a été
le théâtre d'affrontements
communautaires opposant hindous et
musulmans du jamais vu pour cet habitant
à l'origine des tensions
cette procession en l'honneur de hanuman
un dieu de l'hindouisme plusieurs
centaines d'hommes des fils dans le
quartier certains armés de sabres et de
pistolets scandent des slogans violent
et provocateur
pendant leur défilé il hurlait sous nos
fenêtres que tous les musulmans seraient
jetés en prison on finirait découpé en
morceaux une partie de la foule tente
ensuite de pénétrer dans la mosquée
c'est le début d'une nuit de violence
avons vu tous ces individus crier leur
haine devant la mosquée et personne ne
les a arrêtés la police était présente
et n'a même pas cherché à les stopper
alors dites-moi qui sont les vrais
responsables
mais quelques jours plus tard la police
fini par désigner les musulmans du
quartier comme principaux responsables
la municipalité dirigée par les
nationalistes hindous du bjp donne alors
l'ordre de détruire leurs maisons et
leurs magasins une opération punitive
devant les caméras de télévision ont
convié pour l'occasion le tractopelle va
même démolir la grille à l'entrée de la
mosquée sous les regards médusés des
habitants
[Musique]
on va se permettre de faire cela parce
que nous sommes musulmans il n'y a que
cela qui les motive
et ont été détruits l'entrée de la
mosquée et vous appelez ça comment vous
j'appelle cela de l'injustice c'est
totalement illégal
une politique du bulldozer utilisé à
plusieurs reprises par le bjp à travers
le pays à chaque fois le scénario est le
même
après des affrontements provoqués par
des fanatiques hindous les autorités
locales accusent les musulmans et
détruisent leurs habitations affirmant
qu'elles sont illégales
dont le sud de la péninsule une autre
polémique lancée par le parti de la
reine drame audi est venue enflammer le
pays l'interdiction du hidjab dans les
collèges et les lycées de la région du
karnataka une première en inde où le
port de signes religieux a toujours été
autorisée en milieu scolaire aucun autre
culte des visées par la mesure
du jour au lendemain des dizaines
d'étudiants musulmane comme ça poids se
sont vu empêcher d'aller en cours et
d'assister aux examens de fin d'année
avant de le subissent aucune
discrimination nous formions un groupe
uni avec les autres élèves personne ne
nous faisait de remarques mais désormais
tout a changé et ce n'est que le début
nous allons subir de plus en plus de
discrimination maintenant certains
parents disent à leurs enfants ne parle
pas avec ses filles musulmanes je pense
vraiment avoir perdu plusieurs années
après des semaines de manifestations
la haute cour du karnataka validé
l'interdiction du voile à l'école une
victoire pour les groupes
fondamentalistes
à la veille du 75e anniversaire de son
indépendance les valeurs démocratiques
et laïques de l'inde semble s'effriter
chaque jour un peu plus sous les
attaques du nationalisme hindou